ANTHEM.
SHE DID A GREAT JOB.
WATCH.
>> ♪ ♪
>> [CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> Tucker: WELCOME TO TUCKER
CARLSON.
DONALD TRUMP, JR. WILL BE HERE
IN A MINUTE.
FIRST DEVIN NUNES'S 4 PAGE MEMO
WON'T BE THE LAST DECLASSED
DOCUMENT TO SHAKE UP CONGRESS.
THE DEMOCRATIC MEMO WILL BE
RELEASED.
WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO SEE THE NEW
MEMO SOON.
NO MATTER WHAT IT SAYS, THAT'S
PROBABLY A GOOD THING FOR
EVERYBODY.
FOR THE FIRST TIME OF IN
GENERATIONS, AMERICANS HAVE
REASON TO BELIEVE THAT OUR
INTELLIGENCE AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES MISUSED THE POWERS WE
HAVE GIVEN THEM VIOLATING THE
CIVIL LIBERTIES OF AMERICANS AND
TAKING SIDES IN THE POLITICAL
CONTESTS.
AMERICANS DON'T.
THAT'S A DISASTER IN A DEMOCRACY
WHERE TRUST IS KEY.
TRANSPARENCY IS THE ONLY
DECIDE WHAT THEY MEAN.
MAYBE THAT WILL MAKE US TRUST
THE GOVERNMENT AGAIN.
DEMOCRATS DISAGREE.
LAST WEEK PARTY LEADERS AND THE
MEDIA WERE YELLING AT US ABOUT
TO AMERICA.
THEN THE MEMO CAME OUT.
WHATEVER YOU THINK OF THE MEM'S
CONCLUSIONS, YOU HAVE TO CONCEDE
THERE WAS NOT A SINGLE THING IN
THERE YOU SHOULD NOT HAVE BEEN
ALLOWED TO SEE.
REVEALED.
EMBARRASS THEM.
WE SPOKE TO A CALIFORNIA
NONE OF THIS SHOULD HAVE BEEN
SECRET.
WHY DID YOU FIGHT TO KEEP IT
HIDDEN?
HE DIDN'T ANSWER THAT.
HE ACCUSED OF US BETRAYING OUR
COUNTRY.
>> IN THE CASE OF TODAY'S MEMO,
WHAT SPECIFICALLY HAVE I E
ESPOUSED THAT IS A THREAT TO OUR
COUNTRY?
>> YOU ARE PUTTING OUT THE
PUTTIN NARRATIVE BECAUSE THEY
ARE RE-TWEETING THIS.
WHOSE BIDDING ARE YOU REALLY
DOING?
>> Tucker: WHOSE BIDDING ARE YOU
REALLY DOING?
SO FOR WANTING TO SEE THE MEMO,
YOU PROBABLY READ ABOUT THE
McCARTHY ERROR WHERE CONGRESS
MADE BASE WILL CLAIMS OF FOREIGN
COLLUSION AND DESTROYED LIVES OF
AMERICAN CITIZENS.
YOU PROBABLY DIDN'T THINK YOU
WOULD LIVE TO SEE IT HAPPEN
AGAIN BUT IT HAS.
EVIDENCE DO YOU HAVE THAT THE
RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT HACKED JOHN
PODESTA'S EMAIL ACCOUNT.
HERE'S WHAT HAPPENED.
CAN YOU SAY I KNOW FOR A FACT
THE GOVERNMENT OF VLADIMIR PUTIN
WAS BEHIND THE HACKS OF PODESTA?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> Tucker: OF JOHN PODESTA'S
EMAILS?
>> AND ALSO IN EUROPE.
>> Tucker: YOU ARE DODGING THIS.
>> RONALD REAGAN -- YOU ARE
CARRYING WATER FOR THE KREMLIN.
>> Tucker: LOOK.
[OVERLAPPING TALKING].
EKE
SHOW TO RUSSIAN TELEVISION.
>> Tucker: CARRYING WATER FOR
THE KREMLIN.
TREASON IN A SINGLE YEAR, WE
HAVE BEEN ACCUSED OF BETRAYING
OUR OWN COUNTRY BY 20 DEMOCRATS
ON THE HOUSE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE.
PART IS POLITICS OF THE MOST
CYNICAL KIND.
THE DEMOCRATIC BASE HAS BEEN FED
RUSSIAN CONSPIRACY THEORIES FOR
THIS SHOW ERIC WAS RAISING MONEY
ON OUR ATTACK ON THE RULE OF
LAW.
WHAT IF THESE GUYS ARE STARTING
TO BELIEVE THE LIES THEY TELL?
SCHIFF ACCUSED RUSSIA OF A
OUR SECOND AMENDMENT.
HAVE ONE.
>> Tucker: HOW DETERMINED ARE
THE RUSSIAN TO DESTROY AMERICAN
DEMOCRACY?
SO DETERMINED SAID CONGRESSMAN
SCHIFF THAT WILL ATTEMPT TO
PROMOTE OUR OWN BILL OF RIGHTS.
THIS IS DEMENTED.
THERE IS NO OTHER WORD FOR IT.
IT GROWS FROM THE RULING CLASS'S
UNWILLINGNESS TO FACE THE
RESULTS OF LAST YEAR'S ELECTION
SCHIFF IS A MEMBER OF ONE OF THE
MOST IMPORTANT COMMITTEES IN THE
CONGRESS.
THEY ARE SUPPOSED TO BE SOBER
AND THOUGHTFUL AND SMART.
THEY ARE NOT.
IF YOU ASK AN UNCOMFORTABLE
QUESTION THEY ACCUSE YOU OF
WORKING FOR A HOSTILE FOREIGN
DICTATOR.
AND THEY ARE POISED TO TAKE
POWER.
9 MONTHS FROM RIGHT NOW, AT THE
MID-TERMS, THEY MAY.
CHANCES ARE THEY WILL BE RUNNING
CONGRESS AGAIN.
THESE PEOPLE.
CIVIL LIBERTIES.
THEY WILL NUMBER CHARGE.
ADAM SCHIFF WILL BE CHAIRMAN OF